[Music]
hey what's up guys mkbhd here and
welcome to the retail unboxing of the
Samsung Galaxy fold so this is an
interesting one this is the first
foldable phone that's really going on
sale to the masses it's priced way
higher than even any other high-end
Samsung flagship so it's clearly
positioned as a luxury device and so
while you're probably right that most
people won't be buying this some people
will so it's already on sale it's
pre-order so this is what people paying
that $1,980 will get in the box plus a
few bonus the second impressions so if
you haven't already seen my detailed
first impressions video boom it's up
there in the corner or it's the first
link right below that like button so
you're about to see a bunch of examples
of Samsung trying really hard to make
you feel like your money was well spent
so the presentation of the box is you've
seen within a box within a box it's
awesome it's super extra the thin box on
the top is the phone believe it or not
but we're gonna put that to the side for
a second because you do get some other
stuff so in this pouch here at the top
there's a two piece Kevlar case and a
SIM card ejector tool and we'll get back
to that case in a minute then in this
little AKG sleeve here at the top there
are a pair of Samsung Galaxy buds so
these are the hundred $39 wireless
earbuds that you could consider air pods
equivalents in this Samsung or Android
world pretty big inclusion here if you
asked me and since the galaxy fold
doesn't have a headphone jack this is
one step closer to committing to
wireless there's no other dongles just
straight-up wireless headphones then
there's also a fast charger and the USB
C to full size USB dongle in the box and
on the other side and those boxes there
are more rubber tips for the Galaxy buds
and a USB C to USB a cable and then
that's it for accessories which brings
us back to this thin white box from the
top just like the other box it says
galaxy but folded so galaxy fold and
inside is the phone folded flat so
that's why it's so thin I don't know
exactly why they ship it like this if
it's to avoid having a big crease from
the factory or it's just more dramatic
or both or neither I don't know but it
ships flat
is the black one and I'll shut up for a
second so we can get the plastic off it
always fun so putting it up for the
first time the setup process is pretty
much identical to the galaxy s 10 or any
other Samsung phone you sign into your
Google account you sign into your
Samsung Account you can do this on the
front screen or on the inside screen but
like I said in the first impressions
video that keyboard is kind of small so
I prefer the bigger screen and then by
the end of it eventually you end up in
the galaxy fold with this smart stock
black butterfly wallpaper with the pitch
black pixels around the edges in the
middle that is the unboxing experience
now about that case it came with so any
case for the galaxy fold that anyone
makes will either have to be foldable or
come in two pieces this seems like the
smart way to do it it's a two piece
Kevlar sort of flexible material but it
avoids that huge hinge and it has no
moving parts it has adhesive of course
also on the inside that you can line up
to attach it but you don't actually have
to use the adhesive if you don't want to
I found the installation goes on and
comes off just fine and yeah it gets a
little more protected and a little
uglier with the case on it
kind of like with any other case okay
last thing I felt we need to demonstrate
in this quick unboxing and sec
impressions is just how solid these
magnets are I didn't have a mic at the
first impressions but now I do have one
so
that is just super satisfying flip
phones are back and for good reason so
there's a magnet in each side of the
galaxy fold about two-thirds of the way
down as demonstrated by this magnet
paper my new favorite scientific
observation tool and they're pretty
strong so they're so strong that they
have a bit of a field effectively
outside of the phone itself strong
enough to pick up metal objects and
things like a bunch of washers nails or
even whole bags of nails keychains and I
even had a small wrench that worked and
an Apple pencil which of course is a
piece of metal in it for the iPads
magnet that worked and a really really
big allen key it's made of metal and it
can pick it up this magnet is for real
so just had to share that little proof
from what I was talking about from the
last video again I'll link that below
still forming all of my thoughts but man
this thing is really distracting me from
the p30 Pro I've been using that that
review is coming up as well
alongside the retro tech episode one on
the original Gameboy it's a good time to
be a video nerd either way thanks for
watching catch you guys on the next one
peace
[Music]